this is likely just the start of costa
rica's election saga a first round
presidential vote in which a crowded
field of more than two dozen candidates
will be whittled down setting the scene
for a run-off this april
nobody seems to have the 40 percent of
voter support it would take to win
outright analysts say that's because
many of the populists remain
underwhelmed by what's on offer
but there are still front runners let's
have a look
in first place polls lies jose maria
figueres a former president in the 90s
this establishment candidate wants a
second bite and is trading on his
experience to get it although a past
corruption scandal may trip him up
however we see it this country is
falling apart bit by bit i'm offering my
experience in government decision making
and building teams of women and men who
can help us rescue the country and put
it on a different path of green economic
growth jobs combat of poverty and rescue
of national education
second place in the polls lynette
saborio the country's first female vice
president she's hoping that her
scandal-free image and role as ex-head
of costa rica's version of the fbi will
nail her the anti-corruption vote but
she was disappointing in the first
presidential debate and avoided others
we will go hard against impunity we
especially want to put costa rica on the
right path a country that is more just
with more opportunities and fairness for
all people to have the opportunity to
work
in third place there's fabricio alvarado
the surprise package of the elections
four years ago a christian singer with
an anti-gay marriage stance now he's
added infrastructure projects and tax
cuts to his pitch but he's yet to find a
big issue to mobilize his conservative
base this time around
we need to stop governing by hitting the
wallets of costa ricans instead focus on
reactivating the economy and reducing
the sales and salary tax and other
important decisions to take a different
path
but what are people worried by in costa
rica a country which is among the most
prosperous in central america and stable
enough to not even need an army
well there are problems unemployment
lies at almost 20 percent
there's concerns over immigration
especially from haiti and a tourism
industry struggling to recover from the
pandemic
whichever president takes those issues
on they'll need the support of congress
and those seats are up for grabs too
this sunday john holman al jazeera